die bundeswehr wird diesen impfstoff
lagern und sicher 70 millionen impfdosen
so heißt es und dann soll der von dort
verteilt werden in ganz deutschland das
ganze natürlich eine streng geheime
operation wir wollen deshalb hier auch
nicht zu viel zu verraten vor allem
nicht sagen wo genau dieser impfstoff
später gelagert wird aber was wir sagen
können er ist in westdeutschland dieser
stützpunkt und dort wollen wir jetzt hin
schalten zu unserem kollegen markus
hibbeler pardon markus du stehst
mittendrin als sind uns einmal ganz kurz
wie ist die stimmung da vor ort und
kannst du schon irgendwas von besonderen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen sehen ja das
gegenteil von partystimmung ist hier der
fall maximilian wir befinden uns hier in
einem waldgebiet in westdeutschland
näheres können wir nicht sagen um um
näheres können wir nicht sagen um die
sicherheitsbestimmungen einzuhalten
beziehungsweise um die ganze operation
nicht zu gefährden
an diesem wald dieses waldstück grenzt
ein kasernengelände an
und dort soll nach unseren informationen
der impfstoff 70 millionen dosen sollen
ja aus den usa von modena kommen in den
nächsten tagen beziehungsweise wochen
eingelagert werden die stimmung hier ist
verhalten die leute wissen natürlich
logischerweise noch nichts und von
größeren sicherheitsvorkehrung ist hier
an diesem kasernengelände noch nichts zu
sehen
man muss dazu sagen diese region hier
ist eben sehr ländlich die kaserne ist
aber noch in betrieb obwohl natürlich
auch viele standorte hier in
westdeutschland bereits stillgelegt
worden
aber um diese ganze operation nicht zu
gefährden sind welche auch mit nur einem
minimum an licht ausgestattet und wir
befinden uns hier an einem waldstück an
den kasernen gelände direkt mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren